geometric mean okay the geometric mean
are these two values and the extremes
are these two values and there's
something called the means extremes
property you probably know it as the
cross multiplication where this product
equals this product okay but what we're
going to do here is we're going to solve
for the altitude or one of these pieces
of the hypotenuse when you drop an
altitude to the hypotenuse of a right
triangle it splits this hypotenuse into
two parts a and B and what happens is
you hand up with three similar triangles
a small one this medium one and this
over all right triangle and these
triangles are all similar to one another
the corresponding angles are congruent
the corresponding sides are going to be
proportional and what happens is you end
up having a proportion that you can set
up this triangle and this triangle or
the triangle is really compared and I'll
just show you real quick if you take
this triangle okay and you rotate it and
you take this triangle and you rotate it
so you have them in the same orientation
same direction here you've got a and the
altitude here you've got V and the
altitude and you can see you can set up
a proportion so a is 2 the altitude as
the altitude is to B so you're comparing
the base to the base as the height is to
the height so these two triangles are
similar so the corresponding sides are
proportional
but practicality just practically
speaking how do we use this well let's
go over here and look at some examples
if we want to find this altitude here X
all we do is we set up a proportion we
say 4 is 2 X as X is 2 9 so the altitude
okay that's the geometric mean that's
these guys these are the means these are
the extremes
4 & 9 cross multiply so you get x
squared equals 36 and take the square
root of both sides and you get x equals
6 so that's going to be the altitude
okay this one same thing we have a right
triangle we drop an altitude
to the hypotenuse to the base here this
altitude splits the hypotenuse up into
two pieces axon 16 so we know that all
three of these triangles formed are
similar so we can set up a proportion so
same thing access to 8 as 8 is 216 okay
so again you can see the altitude is the
mean okay these are the means and these
are the extremes so if we cross multiply
we get 16 x equals 64 divided by 16 and
we get 4
okay last example sometimes what people
do is they'll give you this whole length
so by taking 29 minus 25 we see that
this is 4
okay and let's just verify that this
works so you can see that 4 is 210 as 10
is 225 100 equals 100 so you can see the
altitude here is the geometric mean of
the two parts of the hypotenuse that it
divides it up into